this look good this is good I'm like
your little sister no oh my oh me oh my
oh my oh yeah yeah yeah yeah you are
here to help you guys cuz obviously
based on how we look and the way we
speak we are professional adult in her
conquering the world one day at a time
so I thought we would do you guys a
service like giving you some advice on
how you can handle the life and things
and stuff as professionally and
awesomely as we do exactly couldn't so I
won't wear nothing am I still speaking
at forward yeah I went on Twitter asked
you guys for what you needed advice on
let's get to it shall we
reaching for entrance note ask her why
she thinks being a youtuber isn't a good
career motivation for my 10 year old
that is hoping to be one huh I would say
YouTube is a great digital resume and
not a great long-term goal true I always
think you can't say that you want to
become a youtuber because that doesn't
mean it right financially doesn't
sustain you like used to belong home
make enough money to live a life that
you want to live I don't need to do
other things but I think it's a great
like creative resource totally ungrate
hobby
yeah we're fun anyone can do it yeah
look at these Muppets that are sitting
here right now
I didn't even go to college but I think
that the idea of youtuber is kind of
insidious because what is the actual
YouTube the great stepping stone to get
there right but to make this long-term
goal just YouTube is the end-all be-all
without interacting with its owner no
you do that there's like three types
there's the person that talks to you
about the dog oh she's so cute
and thank you or the person that talks
to the dog first and then gives you kind
of thing obligatory like the people that
don't speak English it's not
[Music]
get through this year better than when
you started
no one does I told you that do you make
resolutions or anything like that no I
don't lie to myself for fun I think low
expectations maybe high rewards my
therapist says so a lot of time in the
pit you know okay then she said don't
you want to try climb back on so I can
just call right back in it
I'm gonna set up a nice bodega and cash
out I'm giving birth to humans in about
a month how the [ __ ] does that work
whoa Jessie's coming in here the prayer
- you're asking I think the wrong people
on this question
yeah my dog I think was a great eye
opener into how much care actually goes
into keeping something alive yes dogs
are marginally easier than beasts I can
do my dog at home with a door opened her
toilets outside so she's fine yeah you
get in risk if you do that with a baby
which is like yeah dude is 2018 turn 30
in 10 days so what now so you're not 30
yet not yet 28 I'm 32
I never saved nothing really changes I
think honestly being in your 30s is way
better than being in your 20s is you
just no I guess so you don't miss my
guess I just don't keep as much of a
challenge you guys know how to party
Bobby you can do a slide glass of water
yeah I still think mentally I'm like 22
anyway they turned 21 in a month what
should I do
what did you do for your 21st birthday I
tried to like go to a bar and do the
thing and then my brother and sister
decided to come and God lasted so I took
care of them mine was so late went to
TGI Fridays blue and I like came back to
our dorm and like drank a little bit
fell asleep how to deal with him
all right do you know how to fight no
I'm guessing noises - yeah - there was a
dramatic turn to camera and then
hemorrhoids how do you spy with that
mine I was literally just falling asleep
oh that's so funny and then shot I do
feel like a frog except never actually
how to have right Oh first sure yeah
like any authentic Western should have
cameras see I want to see Clint Eastwood
be like hey get out of your bud oh my
how can I make doing my taxes sexy girl
if I knew I'd be doing it oh look what
we're very like are we good
although I've seen you in a dress quick
movie premiere okay if I was part in
character this is literally it's like a
sweatshirt and jeans kind of adorable
yeah but see I wanna be sexy I want to
be I want I want to walk in your home
people come you how would you describe
your style how does one become master of
their destiny on a Saturday night you
truly wouldn't know like how to become
like master your destiny i right now I
like how to have your own like great
Saturday night would it be for you it's
either going out with like a couple
close friends or like going over to
someone's house and like drinking
cooking hanging out or it's like staying
in with my boyfriend drinking cooking
hey what's your ideal Saturday night
well how much all right we'll talk
offline on that no end of our advice
giving me a good meal thank you so much
for being here
James thank you offering such valid
points and fun anecdotes to this
audience hopefully you learned something
if you didn't and our job is done we're
gonna be offended if they don't know
already
Oh at me Oh on Twitter meal monster on
everything else because we always take
it yeah and your podcasts that I'm gonna
be on a future episode yeah what's it
called again punch up the jam it's
really the concept sounds really really
fun
hey where is it on south on iTunes it's
literally everywhere Spotify iTunes I
don't know the rest go check it out and
keep checking out cuz I'll be on there
in the future which I'm very excited
about other than that guys
I don't know I think we're similar
enough that there's nothing I could say
that you haven't already said I mean I
thought I was like I was like I wanted
an advice thing with Turks I think we
have a lot of similar like trains of
thoughts about things I don't post a
video that does get 10 comments saying
oh yeah I mean we're the people no
remember who I am on the Internet I mean
everyone loves you know I'm telling you
as a non youtuber everyone loves you oh
that's very sweet of you I obviously am
great at taking compliments and feeling
emotions I'm just like clutching my
laptop